Every three years we revalue your property
and update your rating valuation or RV.
The RV is what we estimate your property will
sell for on 1 August this year.
The RV isn’t a market value and shouldn’t
be used for insurance or property sales,
it’s purely for the purpose of rates.
It’s important to know that an increase
in your property value doesn't necessarily
mean you’ll pay more in rates.
To explain that, we need to look at how rates
are set:
Rates are just one source of Council income
and their level depends on funding decisions
made by the Council.
Property value only makes up a portion of
your rates; it doesn’t affect fixed charges
rates based on land-area or targeted rates
such as the
kerbside collection service you chose.
Revaluation doesn’t increase the total amount
the Council collects from rates,
instead it helps us work out everyone’s share.
If your property has a lower than average
valuation increase, it’s likely to have
no effect on your rates and in some cases
may mean you pay less.
While a higher than average valuation increase
could result in higher rates.
We won’t know how your new property value will impact your rates until the start of the next rates year.
You can object to your rating valuation and
details on how to do this
will be on the notices sent to property owners.